hey guys we're just getting that
breaking news as you are right now just
hearing that the federal judge has
blocked the administration's effort to
drop this on monday obviously border
patrol agents and texas dps this is
going to be welcome news to them but
really all it's going to do is kick the
can down the road title 42 is going to
have to drop at some point in the future
but that's just not going to be on
monday but even with title 42 in place
we've still seen an explosion in numbers
we just had more than two you know well
over 230 000
migrant apprehensions this last year in
april the highest in dhs history we had
more than 200 000 the month before we've
had more than 1.3 million illegal
crossings since the start of the fiscal
year on october 1st so even with title
42 in place we've seen an explosion in
numbers and what this means now is
for certain countries for certain
demographics the us government will
still be able to expel them back to
mexico meaning that you know we've shown
this video where once people come across
and they are detained by border patrol
rather than having to take them into a
processing center and do paperwork for
hours they're able to essentially just
put them right back onto a bus drop them
off at the port of entry and expel them
back into mexico the whole process can
take
less than an hour they've used it more
than 1.7 million times since march of
2020 that being both the trump
administration and the biden
administration but i can tell you front
line border agents they will be happy to
hear this news because i've been texting
with them for the past several weeks
ever since news came down that they were
planning to get rid of this on may 23rd
and they were basically saying buckle up
because it's going to be total anarchy
and chaos down here at the border dhs's
own projections we're saying upwards of
18 000 illegal crossings a day could
have happened if title 42 were to drop
you do the math on that that's about 540
000 crossings in one single month more
than half a million and just to put that
in perspective that would be more than
double what we just saw last month in
april which was the highest in u.s
history so probably a little bit of a
sigh of relief for border agents in
texas law enforcement but not not too
much because again these numbers have
been exploding even with title 42 in
place you don't have well over 200 000
apprehensions at the border month after
month without there being a serious
surge at the border and we've been
showing the video all day long we keep
getting these massive groups of 150 to
200 crossing every single day so what
does this mean big picture it means that
the administration cannot get rid of
title 42 on monday as planned they have
to keep enforcing it while this
litigation plays out we'll send it back
to you bill you know when you say that
1.7 million since 2020 uh have been sent
back because of title 42. how did they
make a decision that someone should be
sent back based on title 42 we weren't
even covet testing these people so how
did they make that decision
well really it depends what country
they're from and what their demographic
is so it really started off with those
northern triangle countries it would be
guatemala honduras and el salvador at
the time we had agreements with those
countries that we would repatriate the
migrants back to those countries we
would put them on flights or we would
just kick them back to mexico we would
do the same thing with mexicans then
along the way you know once the
administration's changed deals changed
with countries in the in the northern
triangle
nicaraguans for instance they're for the
most part just released once they're
encountered by border patrol because for
the most part they won't take their
citizens back unless they have a
passport cubans are mass released we
don't enforce title 42 with them
venezuelans are released we don't have a
title 42 agreement with them
and one of the criticisms has been that
the biden administration can just
you know put them on a bus and send them
back to mexico but for some of these
demographics they have preferred to put
them on an airplane and send them back
you know they're called repeat
repatriation flights and you know the
yeah the border patrol union says if we
really want to enforce title 42 across
the board just kick everybody back to
mexico the administration hasn't done
that they've preferred to try to fly
some people back and when those host
countries
cooperate they can't do it okay thank
you very much bill millusion you know
the the question that i'm getting at uh
uh lawrence is the fact that
the decision uh to send people back to
the original country has nothing to do
with 42 they're saying 42 but if
nicaragua won't take him back then what
does it matter of title 42 or not so it
seems that 42 is being used in some
cases but not others well
i would say this just based on the
reporting i've done that at the border
42 has been used as a band-aid it's not
going to fix the
big the mass problem that's at the
border
on another and the judge did
the biting administration a favor here
right here but number two
as a result of the the judge making this
decision a lot of women and children are
going to be placed in danger coming
across the board because a lot of the
folks keep asking well why are they
bringing the children across the border
because it's a ticket i mean they know
that they can get across and that this
is why you don't see a lot of people
running away at the border most of the
runners that you said the border are
single dump mills because they realize
that they can't come into the country
under title 42. so this is going to put
our border
patrol agents yet again in a bad bad
position but again it's going to put
these kids and these women in a bag
position as well
jump bite needs to understand this this
is going to be a terrible issue for
those democrats that are on the border
area they are democrats at heart but
what they're saying is they cannot do
this they understand their voters are
putting a lot of pressure on them
because of this issue and i'll just note
this because i know jessa's going to hop
in on this these are latinos too as well
there are 50 over 50 percent of the
border patrol agents are minority when
you look at the texas dps that are doing
a lot of the patrol they are a minority
when you look at those districts that
are at the border they're minority this
is not a matter of if you hate the
people and and you want them to get a
better life this is about law and order
and the strain of resources in those
areas you know jessica the point that
lawrence makes is a good one how is this
going to impact those democrats who are
working along the border who are running
for office well i think it's
a boon on the immigration issue for
democrats at this particular moment
because it gives us a few more months to
listen to democrats like ruben galleo
who most likely is going to challenge
kirsten cinema for her seat in 2024 in
arizona and it feels like a ripe time to
put together some sort of commission
like get will hurd i don't know what
he's doing now that he retired from
congress as a republican and like a
galleo or someone else on the border
together for a bipartisan
plan to do this with title 42 it was a
band-aid and we had a very thoughtful
conversation on the show yesterday about
this issue where
it was acknowledged that this is a
health policy title 42 came into being
because of covid
we're moving towards a world where
hopefully covet is not something that
should be running our immigration policy
what is the next step so hopefully now
we have a few months we have the summer
where there's gonna be very high numbers
of crossings to deal with that and we
can go into november with a clear plan
okay
wrap it up for us
uh well it is a testament how appealing
our systemically racist country is that
millions of non-whites want to come here
but the admit as long as we care about
immigration it's like crime and it's
like inflation the white house won't
because in their view we only view these
concerns because uh we're deplorables
embracing you know replacement theory
when it's all it is and all of these
things whether it is crime or whether
it's inflation or immigration it's about
process it's about rules it's not about
people we're a big republicans and
conservatives and libertarians we're all
about we're all about systems we just
want you to be part of the system and do
it the right way and so what's happening
now you see a lot of people painting a
broad brush of this racism stuff and
this is and this is their way of doing
it here like they did with crime and
elsewhere
go ahead kenny yeah
on the bigger issue of the systems bill
reported earlier today that there was an
american citizen who was arrested in
texas for helping to smuggle illegal
immigrants across the border
bigger picture the longer this
lawlessness goes on and the systems are
disrespected and border patrol's mission
is to process people not to enforce the
border and protect the country that
corruption will breed and it will get
completely out of control and it will
reach public officials it will reach law
enforcement so there's a longer-term
consequence to allowing this type of
lawlessness to continue that and once
it's in those systems we start looking a
lot like the mexican corruption and
that's a lot of the reason why this is
happening as well and once you get to
that point it's really difficult to go
back and the sad part about it is that
with the administration flying people
into the interior of the united states
that corruption is going to spread
quicker than we can imagine hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else